I want to jump to this right here from
Box Office Mojo
sound of Freedom though it's been
attacked relentlessly by many in the
media it has cracked 50 million with a
current domestic box office of 53
million 920 22 551 and massive Success
Through Word of Mouth more and more
people starting to see this film it
looks like the amount of uh gross
revenue being generated is increasing
whereas most films have their big
Blockbuster weekend it goes down this is
the inverse I think this film really is
potentially a starting a movement more
and more people are are getting active
focusing on the issue wanting people
care about the issue there are creepy
people in the media that are smearing it
as Q Anon and other weird things but get
this even with that on Rotten Tomatoes
The Tomato Meter which is the official
corporate press reviewers give it a 75
that surprised me the audience gives it
a 100 with over 10 000 verified ratings
I gotta say we have been praising this
film I think Not only was it masterfully
done it is an entertaining fill it
captures you it makes you feel
at the same time that feeling matters
I've watched I watch movies every day I
watch a different movie every day I've
gone to the theaters yeah I might get a
tear in the eye or something for a good
scene I might get excited for a good
scene but none of it matters you know I
know that Captain America fighting
somebody is just fun but when I watch a
film that's based on a true story and I
see a scene in that film
that I couldn't believe was real and I'm
I'm tearing up I was let me let me let
me put it this way because we're gonna
start getting into spoilers now
there is a part of the film so a warning
to all of you who still want to go see
the movie and don't want to see don't
want to hear spoilers we're telling you
right now but for everyone else who did
we're gonna start getting into some of
the finer details so we can better
understand this because I want to I want
to talk about
one of the most powerful things I've
made reference to in the uh two weeks or
a week or so ago it is when you rescue
this kid on the border so again spoilers
here we go
you are talking to this child
you tell the child your name
and the kid looks up at you and he says
timoteo
he has a necklace that was given to him
by his sister
with Saint Timothy I believe is the uh
what was it first Timothy is first
Timothy 6 11 scripture reference yeah
and he and and when I saw that first of
all my name's Tim so I was just like
whoa like that's crazy for me to hear
and your name's Tim too I know but like
I'm watching this movie this kid is
being rescued from this evil evil man
and this organization you say this is my
name and then he pauses and it seems to
be some kind of like divine intervention
when he says look what I have as if you
were sent specifically to save him I was
on the verge of tears when I saw that
happen I said
I'm like yeah but I wish that really
happened and then you told me it did it
happened and I and I told Alejandro I
said because I have the necklace I mean
I have it's a so it's like Priceless to
me I have it in a vault you know and I
took it out for my to do podcasts and
things I should have brought it here but
um I said don't put this in because No
One's Gonna believe it then it's going
to come off weird and what are the
chances and and uh and and people still
don't think it's real but they still
like it so he was right but it's great
to be able to say it actually happened
and it was a strange moment where um uh
he he you know and it's very accurate it
didn't happen in the garage like you see
uh and the film happened in a different
room uh in the Aftercare Center but he
runs to me and he hugs me and the part
that didn't they didn't pick up in the
film was we were sobbing I'm shaking and
he's shaking and that's before I got the
necklace that's before he just starts
grabbing me and he says to me
um and I think
this was the kind of transformational
moment for me because I didn't know if I
was going to stay in this work
um especially after this this is the
first kid I ever saw by the way who was
in a video before that time I'd only
done videos like you know end user you
know possession cases of child
exploitation material this is the first
time when I saw this kid I knew him I
recognized him I had seen him being
raped his full like through a 30 minute
video
and the his captor was the guy in the
so I'm already on heightened like oh my
gosh it's a real kid this is you know I
never I never seen it and and so we're
I'm coloring with him okay Prager you
you know Prager you oh yeah today today
prageru launched a series called light
in the darkness where they have me
telling some of these stories this
story's told and and is dramatized in a
really cool way and it's more accurate
this and we're sitting there and we're
coloring and I'm trying to get him to
talk because where's your sister where
are the other kids like where he's five
years old right and and up until that
point we've just been kind of friendly
we got close he started trusting me and
it was like just like this like
something just turned on in him and he
just ran over to me and jumped into my
arms like almost like again it was like
an angel said go or something like he
was he didn't ease into it we're just
coloring and then boom he gets up and
runs to me and he jumps into my arms and
he starts shaking crying and I'm crying
like I just lose it you know I've got to
kiss his age you know you start
picturing your own kids you superimpose
your kids faces in the moment right
um and he says these words to me
and it just it is I couldn't I knew at
that time that the stats were millions
of kids so I heard him say this it's
like I heard echoed millions of kids
saying this and it's a simple phrase but
a five-year-old should never have to say
it and he just said
I don't belong here
can you imagine a five-year-old kid
saying I don't belong here no
five-year-old kid would even think to
say that and you know and and he knew he
belonged with his family and and that's
when he pulled the necklace
and he said he said this is my sister
gave me this
and I I I didn't take it I was just like
oh no no you keep it give me a little
card so you see the car in the movie he
gave me the card too and and and I took
it home
and I was so broken up I went home and
and prageru gets into this and there's
in the series as well they just launched
it today
um and I go home and I fall down I fall
down on the I live 10 12 minutes from
the border like you know it's all it's a
small town and I fall down and the
dichotomy of the whole I walk into my
house my kids are happy and they're
playing and they're 10 minutes away from
this kid who has spent the first five
years of his life being sexually
assaulted and and videotaped you know
and my kids are happy and they're only
10 minutes away and I couldn't deal with
it it was like the underbelly of my own
town like and that's everybody's town
and it was so hard for me remember this
is the first kid that I've seen and I I
Collapse on the floor and Catherine
thought I was like having a heart attack
because I I never had this happen I was
exhausted too it was 48 hours or longer
I hadn't slept because the case was so
intense and she didn't know details but
she kind of cradled me like kind of held
me you know
um
and she was like what is going on and I
tried to like get it out and I that's
when I made the decision I I said
Catherine I'm either in a thousand
percent or I'm a thousand percent out
like I have to make a decision right now
because this is too much then my other
kid who's about the same age as this
little boy who plays Miguel's not his
real name but in the film my kid who's
his age takes the necklace he's like
what's this
my kids Jimmy and he says what's this
and uh and I said oh this kid gave it to
me I can't tell Jimmy all what's going
on you know this kid I just helped he's
like oh cool he's looking at it become
curious Jim he's a very curious kid he's
very touchy he looks and everything he's
like oh the kid put your name on it wow
I didn't see it before
um it says man of God on one side on the
other side it says first Timothy 6 11.
with that scripture and he's like how
did how do you put your name on it Dad
I'm like oh he didn't no no he did it
and then he shows it to me and there's
like boom my there's my decision it's a
thousand percent in I know that's for
the sake of filmmaking you guys had to
do it the way you did and it was
masterfully done but that story I'm
sorry is just told naturally is about
it's better here you are not realizing
what you've been given you go home and
you're saying we make this decision and
then your kid's like he gave you your
name tag yeah oh I don't I just want to
say as I'm hearing all this uh
I I don't follow any particular religion
I do believe in God and
atheists or whatever can call me naive
they can scoff but I don't know how you
hear a story like this how you watch a
film like this how you hear about the
work that you've done how you see a
movement like this and believe that
there's not something out there
something more powerful this I can only
describe as and and I'm not maybe it's
not for me to say but I can say divine
intervention I can say it brother I mean
all glory to God I'm holding the
American dream right now as a Mexican
filmmaker eight years of work
so many obstacles so many people saying
you can't do this this is too dangerous
team telling me brother before you guys
commit to do this I need to tell you
something we have a lot of friends
but we have a lot of enemies too and
those enemies will be yours are you sure
you want to do this and I close my eyes
for a second I said what if this is my
son what if this is my daughter what if
this is what if this is my
my niece my my nephew what would I do
you know it was like it was just imagine
that
I will stop everything that I'm doing I
will hope then I will hope that the
entire world will stop everything
they're doing so they can help me to
find my son my daughter my niece my
nephew right okay so that's my
motivation don't wait until this tragedy
happens to you for you to wake up right
Wake Up Now do something and and and I
can't believe that
you know Angel Studios is the smallest
this region company in America right so
after three years of everyone passing
like no this is not for us now this
movie is not a business for US ah this
is not a good business for us this is
not for us so three years of like doors
being close and close and close and
close and you have two options either
you give up or you don't give up we
choose the second one we don't give up
why because it's about saving children
what if this is your son what happened
after I I'm praying for God to send an
angel to rescue this film
and I got a phone call from Angel
Studios hey uh we're very interested in
your movie do you have any other options
no you're my only option okay well let's
close the deal five days later we send a
contract and okay this is three and a
half months ago right three and a half
months ago and then okay when when when
are we coming out July 4th what brother
we don't have I mean we don't have like
money for publicity or marketing the
biggest films in the world are going to
come out July 4th week before and week
after mission impossible
Indiana Jones competing with the biggest
company in the world they have hundreds
of millions of dollars are you kidding
Eduardo
is very important July 4th because it's
Independence Day Freedom we need to
check the conscience of America because
yes let's celebrate let's celebrate
freedom in one hand but let's do
something else so we can bring freedom
back to those children that are not free
brother let's do something we never
thought that July 4th son of Freedom was
number one movie in America this is a
miracle we
all glory to God
people like to make jokes that we live
in a simulation
yeah and it's because reality seems to
be too absurd we've had so many weird
goings on in politics of President
Donald Trump and so you'll see many of
these individuals who are secular
atheists tweet things like I hope the
writers of this season you know do X Y
or Z as if to imply there is someone
with greater power over us that they're
starting to believe yet I always find it
funny that they could entertain such an
idea without realizing like you're
literally talking about Divine Purpose
or God
I bring that up because
seeing seeing the movie hearing the
stories
it feels like I'm like I mentioned the
timateo necklace thing I'm like that was
masterful writing I wish it was real
well it was real and then you start to
realize that some things in life
are are so miraculous that you would
assume it was written to be a story that
it never could really happen but these
things do happen
when that kid when you when you told the
story of the of the little kid saying I
don't belong here no five-year-old
should say that
my thought was why would a five-year-old
say that unless what was happening was
so out of alignment with the the law of
nature whatever you want to call it with
with the with God's plan or whatever
that there was direct intervention to
correct this evil and said it right
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time